enough and three people seriously
injured after an incident that's taken
place at a private school in Devon we
understand police were called at around
1am because of a serious assault in
Tiverton they were called to a building
on the site of blundell's school in
Tiverton following reports of a series
of assault where it was reported that
three people including two students had
been assaulted and had sustained serious
multiple injuries they've been taken to
hospital for treatment a 16 year old boy
from Tiverton has been arrested on
suspicion of three counts of causing
Grievous bodily harm with intent now he
remains in police custody at this time
the superintendent who is working on the
cases said this is a very traumatic
incident for those involved and The
Wider School community and we will
continue to work closely with the school
this is blunder School providing support
to those involved at this time it's
understood that all parties involved are
linked to the school I'm Keen to
reassure the community that there is no
wider risk and we are not seeking anyone
else in relation to this matter they're
continuing their searches and inquiries
in the vicinity of the school and they
are in the early stages of their
investigation so three seriously injured
three students seriously injured after
an incident at Blundell School in near
Tiverton in Devon